[Music]
straight ahead on Law and crime daily a
deadly shooting spree in Memphis
Tennessee the people of our city were
confronted
with the type of violence no one should
have to face what we know so far about
the suspect and The Disappearance and
death of Eliza Fletcher suspect cleotha
abstin appears in court for the third
day in a row plus a surprising arrest in
the murder of a Las Vegas investigative
reporter this has been an unusual case
from the beginning
the murder of an investigative
journalist and the main suspect an
elected official at later the
honey Massacre keeper dive into the
lives of the Wagner family a look ahead
to the trial of George Wagner IV law on
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
and welcome everybody to law and crime
daily I'm Brian Ross sitting in today
for Brian buckmeyer we begin with news
out of Memphis where people in that city
of more than a million residents were
ordered to shelter in place after our
gunman live streamed a shooting spree on
Facebook it happened on Wednesday when
officials say 19 year old Ezekiel Kelly
started the deadly spree just before one
o'clock in the morning they say Kelly
traveled from the east side of the city
to the South side and then back again in
all creating at least eight separate
crime scenes at one point they say the
gunman live streamed a shooting on
Facebook what a concerned citizen called
in that tip Memphis Police launched a
city-wide search for Kelly who they
described as armed and dangerous the bus
and trolley systems were also suspended
as law enforcement urged residents to
stay inside after carjacking a number of
vehicles and leading investigators on a
high-speed chase Kelly was arrested just
before nine o'clock Wednesday evening
and at a press conference Memphis mayor
Jim Strickland said Kelly was released
from a three-year prison sentence early
back in March of this year after
accepting a plea deal for a charge of
criminal attempted first degree murder
these evil actions
show why truth and sentencing is a must
and we should do all we can to make our
city safe
we should not be terrorized
by anyone
anyone who wants to strike fear in our
hearts
and take away what we love about Memphis
we must unite around this principle
and stand up
to the challenge of violent crime in our
city
if Mr Kelly
served his full three-year sentence
he would still be in prison today
and four of our fellow citizens
would still be alive
joining us now is co-host Terry Austin
and criminal defense attorney Jack Rice
in Minnesota Jack let me start with you
this mass shooting was carried out in at
least eight separate locations that's
quite a challenge now for law
enforcement as they gather up evidence
isn't it
yeah you're absolutely right it's not
just the eight crime scenes it's all the
space in between right so normally what
we want to see is if you see a enclosed
crime scene you can coordinate
coordinate it quarantine it off and then
work your way inward from there the
problem that we have here is it
stretches from east side to the South
and back and now you're trying to
compare those look at those some of
these obviously tie to one individual
but not necessarily always so you're
having to do a lot of a lot of work on
this and exponentially it becomes much
more difficult
Terry Austin as we heard the mayor say
Kelly was previously charged with
attempted first degree murder but
pleaded to a lesser charge and was
released after serving just 11 months
the mayor said if they had kept him in
jail for his full three-year sentence
four victims would still be alive today
do you agree with that
absolutely disagree with him on that
statement look I agree that a lot has to
be done to make sure these types of
crimes don't happen again but it does
seem as though Kelly was a time bomb
just waiting to happen and whether he
served 11 months or three years he
clearly was not rehabilitated and the
previous charges when he was only 17 he
was 19 now but the previous charges
included attempt to first-degree murder
aggravated assault and reckless
endangerment with a firearm so although
that prior attack did not end in a death
it does show his capacity for hate and
for violence and so one of the things I
think we need to do is determine how
into possession of that firearm plus we
have to figure out what the motive was
and if he needs mental help then that's
one of the things I think we should do
those are the things that could probably
prevent a crime like this from happening
all right thank you Terry Austin Jack
Rice turning now to South Carolina where
a lawsuit involving the ongoing Alec
Murdoch Sega will head to trial next
month without anyone from the Murdoch
family being involved the suit involves
a wrongful death complaint from the
family of 19 year old Mallory Beach who
died in a boating accident in February
of 2019 the boat allegedly driven by a
drunk and underage Paul Murdoch and
owned by his father the disgraced
attorney Alex Burdock slammed into a
bridge piling ejecting all six
passengers and killing beats the lawsuit
was filed against both the murdochs and
the owner of the convenience store where
Paul purchased the alcohol while
underage Burdock previously requested
the wrongful death case be separated
from his other charges that he shot and
killed his wife Maggie and their son
Paul years after the boat accident a
judge granted the request saying the
case that the Beach's family filed
against the convenience store will go to
trial October 10th while the suit
against Murdoch's will be delayed until
next year
still ahead on law on crime daily an
elected official is arrested for the
murder of a veteran Las Vegas reporter
but first the man accused of Eliza
Fletcher's abduction and murder appears
in court for the third day in a row
[Music]
and welcome back the suspect in the
abduction and murder of Memphis
Tennessee teacher Eliza Fletcher appears
in court for the third time in three
days for a motions hearing over a
possible conflict of interest with the
public defender's office 38 year old
cleotha abson was initially charged with
kidnapping and tampering with evidence
but that was later charged to
first-degree murder when Fletcher's body
was found days after she went missing
investigators say 34 year old Fletcher
was last seen alive on Friday September
2nd just after 4 a.m in the morning
while out on a run she was forced into a
black SUV investigators later determined
abstin was driving the vehicle he was
arrested on Saturday on Monday
Fletcher's body was found near an
abandoned Hall Thursday morning he was
arraigned on charges of murder and the
judge determined that the Shelby County
Public Defender's office will represent
abstin despite the fact that they rep
presented him in 2001 when he pleaded
guilty for a separate kidnapping charge
for which he served 20 years in prison
after the set to return to court Monday
September 19th so Terry Epson already
served 20 years in prison for a prior
kidnapping charge so much for the
concept of Rehabilitation is there any
test any way to determine if inmates are
no longer a threat to the community
that's an excellent question Brian and
this is yet another traffic case
happening in Memphis and like the mass
shooting we just talked about you have
to wonder what was the motive here and
could this death have been prevented he
actually served the 20 years as you
mentioned and that was for aggravated
kidnapping and that's a crime that's
punishable in Tennessee by eight to
thirty years he served 20. so he served
a good amount of time one could argue
that that was a sufficient amount of
time plus you know he has constitutional
rights as does any defendant for equal
protection due process but perhaps we
should have looked at this prisoner we
should have made sure that he was
rehabilitated we should have looked at
whether or not he might need some mental
help and one of the things things I
think we can think about is just like a
parole board looks at people who get out
early perhaps we can look at individuals
who are getting out of jail trying to
make sure they don't return and asking
them questions which will help us
determine whether or not they are
actually really ready to get out for
release and whether they'll be safe for
the community that they are living in
right Jack Rice Tennessee is a death
penalty state what's the likelihood of
the prosecution in this case will seek
the death penalty
when we think about the death penalty
and we think about this particular case
it's a stranger on Stranger case in the
first place it's a murder case it may
even be a sexual assault case simply
because they found clothing her shorts
in a bag separate from that that's a
piece of this that could make it the
death penalty but as importantly you can
look at his prior record and you look at
the 20 years that he already served when
you combine all of that this is the kind
of case where people will look at it and
they will say yes the death penalty
could apply it's first degree murder the
options are uh life without parole life
with the possibility of parole or as you
just asked the death penalty that's
exactly what this prosecutor is talking
about right now all right Jack Rice
Terry Austin thank you so much moving
North now to Canada the search for the
second suspect and a string of fatal
stabbings dies following his arrest
after he and his brother allegedly
killed 10 people and injured more than a
dozen others in Saskatchewan province
officials say Brothers miles and Damien
Sanderson are responsible for the Sunday
morning stabbing attacks that took place
across 13 different locations officials
say some of the victims may have been
targeted by the suspects While others
were attacked at random they say the
victims range in age from 23 to 78 on
Monday authorities announced that one of
the suspects Damien was found dead with
injuries that are not believed to have
been self-inflicted late Wednesday night
the other brother miles was taken into
custody after he stole a woman's car and
led police on a high-speed chase he
later died from what were called
self-inflicted injuries according to
officials around 10 victims remained in
the hospital some are still in critical
condition
coming up on Law and crime daily we look
ahead to opening statements in the Pike
County Massacre case out of Ohio plus
investigative reporter Jeff gurman is
stabbed to death outside his home now
police have arrested a local politician
who was the subject of the reporter's
investigative stories
[Music]
welcome back to Long crime daily and a
shocking murder story out of Las Vegas
where police have arrested a local
politician in the murder of an
investigative reporter prize-winning
investigative reporter Jeff girvin of
the Las Vegas Review Journal was stabbed
at us outside his home on Saturday
because of the Relentless follow-up of
our detectives and with your help I'm
here to announce the rest of 45 45 year
old Robert Tellis this is a terrible and
jarring homicide
one that has deeply impacted Las Vegas
every murder is tragic
but the killing of a journalist is
particularly troublesome
who hope the rest of Telus and the
subsequent prosecution will ultimately
provide a sense of justice for our
community
and Mr garman's family
earlier this week police released images
of a suspect seen in German's
neighborhood in a bright orange shirt
and white brim a wide brimmed hat hiding
his face German known for his
hard-hitting investigations of
government corruption and the mob had
recently published a series of
investigative stories on Telus accusing
the official of abusing the resources of
his office bullying staff and having an
inappropriate relationship with a female
staffer who was seen in the back seat of
a car with Ellis who is married tell us
who lost his bed for re-election
following the newspaper expose strongly
denied the charges in an interview with
German later lashing out against the
reporter on Twitter
earlier today I spoke with Las Vegas
Review Journal investigative reporter
art Kane who worked side by side with
government
Jeff was a hell of reporter and
according to what we're seeing so far
that's what got him killed that's what
it appears to be I I'll tell you I'm
surprised we thought it was probably a
robbery gone bad until yesterday when it
all came down to being this guy who he
wrote about but to have a elected
official kill a journalist for a story
he did a fair story an accurate story no
Corrections is just completely appalling
and unheard of
indeed Telus was last seen being carried
out of his home on a stretcher and put
into an ambulance as he was arrested so
Terry any murder is disturbing but as
the Las Vegas officials say this was the
murder of an investigative reporter
doing his job should there be harsher
punishments for this type of murder as
with police or Court Personnel oh I
definitely think so all murders like you
said Ryan are disturbing but if
something particularly heinous when you
murder an authority or a public official
or a police officer and I will include
in that group investigative reporters
like yourself these are public servants
and they're simply doing their jobs and
their roles are critical to our society
for the orderly function of our society
and many states frankly because of that
have special codes penal codes that have
stricter penalties for the murder of
police officers public officials
firefighters emergency workers and those
codes say that when you kill someone who
is in one of those categories you will
get a harsh sentence New York for
instance has that type of Penal Code so
I definitely think that reporters should
be in that category and it is disturbing
to think that a public official could
actually kill someone who is simply
writing a story right uh Jack as you
know the irony here is that German who
reported extensively on the mafia was
never really threatened by the Mobsters
who of course have a track record of
violence so do you think the news of
this tragic murder will have a chilling
effect on other investigative
journalists who are out there pursuing
controversial stories
you know I certainly hope not because we
realize the contribution that
journalists have in society to put this
mirror up against those and say who are
we what are we doing why are we doing it
that is critical but it's always odd
because when we think about some of the
threats that come at people you'd
imagine they'd come from some places
like in the criminal world one of the
places we sometimes would expect would
be serious criminal offenses that's not
where they come from the lawyers who are
actually facing the biggest threats are
frequently family lawyers those who
because of emotional connections because
of somebody whose life is spinning out
of control it makes it that much harder
that always makes it really unusual it
really does You Know Jack as an
investigative reporter for decades I
have been slugged punched but never had
a death threat when we come back the
Pike County Massacre long crime networks
and net Levy gives us a closer look at
the family at the center of the crime
[Music]
and welcome back we're looking ahead now
to the trial of George Wagner IV and
taking a deeper dive into the family of
the center of Ohio's Pike County
Massacre and how authorities say they
operated long crimes Anjanette Levy
shows us what other acts prosecutors say
supports their case for murder
prosecutors say that the Wagners lived
an insular lifestyle focused on
controlling the children and the young
women who entered Their Lives Jake
Wagner pleaded guilty to 23 charges
including eight counts of aggravated
murder in the deaths of his
ex-girlfriend and her family prosecutors
say the Wagners lived in insular life
focused on control of children and the
young women who entered their lives 28
year old Jake Wagner admitted he and his
family plotted and planned for months to
murder Hannah May Rhoden and any members
of her family who stood in the way of
Jake getting sole custody of their
daughter a notice from prosecutors to
introduce other acts evidence claims
Jake Wagner assaulted controlled chased
and threatened to kill Hannah Rhoden
during their relationship and put her
body where it would never be found
prosecutors make similar claims against
the Wagners involving Jake's older
brother George and his ex-wife and their
son the prosecutor wrote that the
Wagners got the woman to sign away all
almost all of her custody rights under
false pretenses and then kept the child
from her the murders in April 2016 were
shocking eight members of the Rhoden
family shot in the head as they slept in
four locations when the Wagners moved to
Alaska in 2017 Jake Wagner married a
young woman court documents say the
Wagners threatened to kill the woman and
became upset when Jake's daughter
started referring to her as Mom part of
the plea agreement for Jake Wagner
included taking the death penalty off
the table for his mom his father and his
older brother George Angela Wagner
pleaded guilty in September of last year
both she and Jake have agreed to testify
against George and Billy Wagner George
Wagner's trial is expected to start next
week after being delayed for Law and
crime daily I'm Anjanette Levy
Antoinette thank you very much Jack Rice
two members of the Wagner family have
already pleaded guilty in this
incredible Family Feud and agreed to
testify against the other two now what
are the chances that the brother or the
father will also decide to take a plea
deal somebody has to be prosecuted right
well they do and one of the things that
is going to happen here is there is a
lot of pressure on these two to plead
the idea that they could be facing the
death penalty and simply saying do we
want to fix this or not but contemplate
what it's like when you have family
members who are willing to take the
stand against you they can take you
inside you can have the mom in this case
take the stand and literally dissect
their children in front of them at the
same time anytime you see something like
this you're going to have jurors who may
very well question the emotive of those
very same people who pled guilty and had
to cooperate because that's part of this
agreement I mean we use the term snitch
regularly and it actually sticks
sometimes there are those jurors who
will simply reject what's being said by
somebody if they got a deal in order to
testify and these people did
so Terry Austin eight people were killed
allegedly by four different defendants
so who pulled the trigger and how did
the prosecution how do they prove that
well one thing here is it's a conspiracy
so they don't have to necessarily do
that but hopefully the forensic evidence
is going to help to tell the real story
here they're going to have to focus on
the ballistics I think that's really
critical here they're going to have to
trace the gun purchases and they should
be able to do that and they also need to
trace that ammunition where did it come
from who bought it they're going to have
to also figure out the DNA evidence at
the multiple sites as we know eight
people were killed they were in their
beds there were multiple sites hopefully
we have some fingerprints hopefully have
some DNA at any of those sites and then
as Jack was referring to we have the
testimonies of Jake and Angela now Jake
is the one whose child it was that was
the center of this custody battle but we
have him testifying we have Angela
testifying and they both pled guilty so
theoretically they're going to clarify
which of those Wagners went to which of
those homes to kill the members the
eight members of the Rhoden family and
the Gilly families so with the forensics
and with the witnesses we should be able
to determine who exactly pulled those
triggers what an ugly emotional case
Jack Rice Terry Austin thank you so much
for joining us here on Law and crime and
thanks to all you we'll see you next
time here on Long crime as we discuss
Justice in America
[Music]
foreign
[Music]